hello Ghana hello my name is Nana
hammock Brown and I'm bringing you make
Browns kitchen I want to say very big
thank you to all my sponsors tasty Tom
the only tomato mix with vitamins and
fiber awake mineral water I wake
purified drinking water
remember that delay McCrady a non patent
pending launch a kitchen Fuad aroma
Borgias olive oil one Wow
my hair is from booty whoa
my makeup is I do a makeover my drag is
from sheet collection I am going to
introduce you a wonderful gentlemen all
the way from America
oh I love Ghana I went to the
marketplace today I danced I met people
do you like my dancing what did that
mean you know you mentioned your
products I'd like to mention my sponsor
you do mcnulty wigs mcnulty wigs if it's
not a mcnulty it's not a wig
and dr. Fishman did my facial surgery
I'm 77 years old you are
we're cooking a famous Ghana jollof ah
yes we have peas yeah and then this I
don't this looks like a car accident I
don't know what this is this is ginger I
am ginger yes yeah ginger all over for
77 years there you nae t7 sorry I think
I've aged since I've been here ladies
and gentlemen it's a song that I sing
we're going to put small blended stuff
here yes do that now small not all why
do you look at me you keep looking at me
you say yes like you know okay yes yes
no no yes no no yes no no yes yes open
it open the blender yes ma'am
we got that now get the cameraman laughs
yes I have a good friend who's a big
star in America wow it's a thing you
know we're cooking your love and tell
him what we're cooking wet will cook who
would taste tasty Tom tomato me if it's
not tasty Tom it says not rather eat a
bomb Wow he can chop it he's good
couldn't I'm sure he's better than you
see someone chopped a carrot not like
this the corners
looks delicious Kuna Oh Sam what are you
going to tell you people about your
country I'm gonna tell them god it's the
most beautiful country in the world I'll
see you again next week but then I have
to say thank you too
hi says faces ha yes yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]